cela dit il faut que je me mange là
dessus au fond des forêts le loup
l'emportent et puis le mange sans autre
forme de procès jean de la fontaine
la raison du plus fort est toujours la
meilleure c'est en tout cas ce que
montre le loup et l'agneau écrit en 1668
par jean de la fontaine à l'orangerie du
château de versailles 450 élèves de cm2
étaient réunis pour recevoir un
exemplaire de ces fables une initiative
menée par le ministère de l'éducation
nationale
les fables de la fontaine ont quelque
chose d'éternel tunnel d'abord elle
fonctionne à tous les âges c'est à dire
ça plaît aux enfants aux adolescents aux
adultes
et puis elles nous disent quelque chose
d'éternel puisqu'il ya toujours une âme
une morale des fables de la fontaine
et puis il ya une forme des fables de la
fontaine qui tout simplement nous mène
au beau c'est l'école du bien du vrai du
beau ce sont les trois notions qui sont
derrière tous les toutes les
transmissions de savoirs et toutes les
transmissions de valeur et donc la
fontaine fait partie de ces écrivains
qui d'une certaine façon rassemble tous
à un recueil enrichie par les dessins de
l'illustrateur johann sfar auteur du
chat du rabbin l'objectif donner goût à
la lecture
l'idée c'est d'offrir un livre illustré
pour amener à mener une peut-être une
petite habitude qui est mon ami ni
scolaire ni éducative qui à un moment de
liberté où on s'approprie un texte dans
les fables de la fontaine ça me semble
essentiel parce que ce sont de petites
chansons elles sont très ironique elles
ont un aspect oui un petit peu provocant
on est là ça peut critiquer ou le
pouvoir ou la famille ou les proches
d'en face et s'est fait pour se moquer
de ce qui nous entoure et voir les
travers des uns et des autres j'aime
bien j'aime bien les dessins c'est
émouvant
il est bien et les dessins et son bo5
d'une belle histoire moi j'aime bien
lancée en 2010 est un livre pour les
vacances a permis cette année à huit
cent mille élèves de cm2 de toute la
france d'obtenir leurs ouvrages
une opération qui sera renouvelée tous
les ans avec un dessinateur différent